[Música]
eu queria saber aqui é quem já se
imaginou jogando tudo pronto
pedindo demissão criando uma nova rotina
nem de viver uma nova vida aqui delícia
eu acho que todo trabalhador já se
imaginou em algum momento em uma
realidade desagradável ou no mínimo
menos difícil né porque afinal o que
todo mundo quer nessa vida é ser feliz
quem não quer ser feliz e na internet
parece que todo mundo feliz demais o
tempo todo né
você fica lá vendo os casais que parecem
está sempre viajando as carreiras
profissionais que parecem está sempre
deslanchando
as famílias que parecem ter saído de um
comercial de margarina e claro muitos
muitos muitos textos dizendo como a
felicidade o sucesso depende só de você
e mais nada
será um ano eu escrevi um texto chamado
a juventude que não pode largar tudo pra
viajar o mundo ouvem de brigadeiro é e
escrevi isso por dois motivos principais
o primeiro porque como jornalista eu
estava sentindo que tinha algumas coisas
que precisavam ser ditas e não estavam
sendo e segundo porque é de verdade eu
estava de saco cheio de todo dia lê como
devia parar tudo o que estava fazendo na
europa esse lance é pois bem eu escrevi
isso correndo no linkedin gostei foi
embora dormir e na manhã do dia seguinte
acordei como what's up bombando dos
amigos mensagens no facebook de pessoas
que eu nunca vi na minha vida
e aí eu percebi que eu não era a única a
tarde saco cheio
eu percebi também como no nas redes
sociais a gente parece que
se esquece como a gente vive numa
sociedade que é extremamente injusta e
extremamente desigual
a gente fica lá vendo aquelas fotos
maravilhosas todo mundo com o seu
sucesso e é claro que a gente quer tudo
aquilo pra gente mas será que o que tá
lá se encaixa na nossa realidade ou às
vezes a gente fica que nem aquela
criança pequenininha tentando colocar a
estrelinha no buraco do ciclo e aí não
vai rolar
e como acontece com tudo que a gente
tenta se encaixar e não consegue
a gente se frustre e é uma frustração
até um pouco rancorosa você fala olha lá
tá todo mundo assinando bem maior
sucesso eu aqui será que eu sou
incompetente
se você em algum momento já se sentiu um
pouquinho pra macho parece que está
dando certo pra todo mundo que você não
eu vim aqui pra te falar não se avexe
não fica assim não porque a gente vive
num país onde a média salarial é de 2
mil reais por mês mas a média salarial
não quer dizer que a maior parte dos
brasileiros receba ou possa contar com
dois mil reais todos os meses pelo
contrário até 2010 de acordo com o
último lançamento de dados do ibge 60%
de brasileiros viviam com até um salário
mínimo por mês 60 por cento dos
brasileiros são 115 milhões de pessoas
agora vamos ao salário mínimo tá aí por
volta dos 930 reais
uma família que seja no caso um pai uma
mãe das crianças será mesmo que eles vão
ter com 930 reais por mês as mesmas
possibilidades do que eu do que você
e dentro dessa família será que a mãe
mulher vai ter as mesmas oportunidades
que o pai e os filhos mais jovens as
mesmas possibilidades
mas mais velhos então esse negócio de
dizer de igualdade de oportunidade
não dá para a gente dizer isso né não é
todo mundo que pode fazer com uma amiga
raquel fez a raquel foi ótima
ela pediu demissão foi para a itália
estudou moda foi morou na alemanha
foi lindo mas a raquel não tem filhos
por exemplo ela não é arrimo de família
não têm nenhuma renda dela ela tem
ensino superior completo pós graduação
os pais da raquel também têm ensino
superior completo ou pós-graduação
aí eu estava falando com esses dias no
facebook e ela me disse lá vão mais
mudar não foi fácil nem assim é claro
que não foi mudar não é fácil nunca pra
ninguém só tem uma pessoa extremamente
consciente ela sabe que por ela ter a
possibilidade de fazer essa mudança na
vida dela é sim uma pessoa privilegiada
outro exemplo a jéssica eu amo a jéssica
ea jéssica assim como todos nós aqui
tinha um sonho sonho dela era empreender
abrir um pet shop ela estudou se
planejou e quando foi possível foi o que
ela fez
só que quando a gente abre um negócio
esse negócio precisa de um tempo até
começar a dar lucro
e nesse período ela precisava manter
emprego pra manter a família
e aí começaram a surgir algumas
dificuldades entre elas uma coisa que só
de ouvir eu me arrepio chamada crise
e aí a jéssica teve que fazer uma
escolha meio forçada bastante esforçado
mas ela fez ela manteve o emprego para
manter a família
ela teve que abrir mão do sonho não pra
sempre ali naquele momento
um foi uma tentativa
quantas tentativas os médicos fazem até
conseguir achar a cura para uma doença
até achar uma vacina e tem doença que
até hoje não tem cura que até hoje não
tem vacina
são gerações e gerações e gerações
tentando falando em gerações
minha avó ela sempre me contava uma
história que o meu bisavô pai dela
quando ele é trabalhar na cidade grande
que no caso é são paulo ele vinha lá no
interior de longe das cruzes e quando
ele voltava isso eu tô falando de 1940 e
poucos ele levava uma maçã de lembrança
e essa uma maçã era dividida entre ele
ea mulher dele e as filhas entre seis
pessoas
ele ficava lá hora de todo mundo está
levando em cima da maçã uma maçã era um
artigo de luxo e ainda é um artigo de
luxo para muitas pessoas
pra muita gente e eu estou encontrando
essas histórias pra vocês só pra ajudar
a gente a lembrar que existem muitas
histórias como já foi dito aqui muitas
realidades que então não dá pra gente
olhar para alguém falar se eu consegui
qualquer pessoa consegue só fez passar
eu não tô dizendo que a gente tem que se
conformar com o que a gente tem não esse
nunca jamais
o que eu estou dizendo é que não existe
uma fórmula pronta para o sucesso onde
todo mundo vai se encaixar
o tac e que se você não achou a sua
fórmula para o sucesso não tem problema
não tem problema então se você tem uma
idéia ou o ideal de sucesso seja teu
emprego seja empreender corra atrás faça
tudo o que estiver ao seu alcance para
fazer dar certo mas se não der certo
a vida tá aí pra gente tentar outra vez
tentar de novo tentar de outro jeito
porque o sucesso não é tão fácil e nem
tão rápido quanto ele pode parecer não
se esqueçam disso
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]